ما دار في ذهنك عندما
سمعت تلك التعليقات من الرئيس
الليلة الماضية ، لقد كان نوعًا من الصدمة من
الفزع لأنني كنت تعلم دائمًا
أن هذا كان احتمالًا ولكن
هناك بعد ذلك عملية كيفية
التعامل معها ومن ثم كيف يمكنك
اتصل فعليًا وأخبر عائلتك
أن الرئيس يسخر
منك عندما تكون ضحية
جريمة أعني واليوم
قال الرئيس إنه لا يندم على ما
قاله أعتقد أن هذا لا يفاجئك ،
لا.  ليس شخصًا
غطى حقًا هذا الرئيس في الحملة
الانتخابية لمدة 18 شهرًا ، فأنا على دراية كبيرة
بمنظمته التي تعرف
أنها أجرته عدة مرات
ولم يفاجئني ذلك
، أتمنى لو أتمنى لو كان لديه
فاجأني ذلك ، لكن كان الأمر كذلك
بالنسبة لجميع الرؤساء الذين تحدثوا عن أن جان
فورتي كان رجلاً صعبًا
وملف تعريف ارتباط قاسيًا ، أعني أنه كان ملف تعريف ارتباط قاسيًا
لدرجة أنه كان مضللًا في البداية حول
ما فعله لك بالفعل كما كان
اشخاص  في حملته ، نعم لا ،
كذب علي حتى أدرك أنه كان هناك
صوت وشهود عيان تعلمون
أنه لم يكن من تصرفات
ملف تعريف ارتباط قاسي ، فإن ملف تعريف الارتباط القاسي لا يهاجم
شخصًا من العدم دون
استفزاز لطرحه سؤالاً حول
الرعاية الصحية  السياسة التي سألتني عنها الشرطة في الواقع
بعد ذلك ، هل هناك أي شيء
عن مكتب الميزانية في الكونجرس
ربما يكون قد أثار إعجابه ومن ثم
الرجل الذي يقول إن هذا ليس
عمل ملف تعريف ارتباط قاسي هذا هو
عمل جبان نعم
ويكذب جبان بشأنه  وهو ما فعله وفعله أعضاء
حملته كذلك ، لذا
أعني أنني أجد أنه من المدهش حقًا
أن يشيد الرئيس به على أنه
ملف تعريف ارتباط قاسي عندما يكون هذا الرجل قد
اعتدى عليك من العدم وهذا
يكذب بشأنه  أمر لا يصدق بالنسبة
لي المنشور ، قالت صحيفة الغارديان في
بيان إن الرئيس يجب أن
يعتذر عن هذه التعليقات ، هل تريد
اعتذارًا ، أعني أنه سيكون رائعًا إذا
كان هناك ما لا أفعله  حبس أنفاسي
، أعني أن قلقي لا يتعلق
بمواقفي بقدر ما يتعلق الأمر بجمال
خاشقجي وكل شيء يدور في
العالم ، حيث تنخفض الإشارة حول
كيف ترى الولايات المتحدة وكيف
ينظر الرئيس الولايات المتحدة إلى الصحفيين عندما يستقبل
44 صحفيًا.  قُتلت هذا
العام ، ما هو القلق حقًا من
أنك تعرف أن ما أمر به ليس
ممتعًا ، ولكن هناك أشخاص
يبلغون جميع أنحاء العالم في الوقت الحالي ،
كما تعلمون خوفًا على
حياتهم وهذا ما يفعله  كما تعلمون هو
شيك على بياض للحكومات التي تريد أن تتخذ إجراءات
صارمة ضد الصحافة الحرة في الأماكن
التي لا يوجد فيها الأول